on joue bien je vais plus léger la série
4 j'adore moi c'est mon moment préféré
de la semaine dernière je les ai pas vus
j'étais pas bien et la semaine prochaine
je les ai pas d'ailleurs je suis sur la
peau ni annuler votre voyage
hradecka tire quand même ouaip autres
elle a voulu une question page ou bien
allons y va c'est gérard bonjour je
m'appelle gerard j'ai appris que vous
alliez amené pas mal de vos chroniqueurs
en laponie
donc j'aurai une requête vous serait-il
possible d'en abandonner certains à bas
on part jeudi prochain aux médias comme
des oufs alors il y en a qui sont pas
encore sélectionné merci j'ai pas mon
billet vert a pour l'instant où vous ne
venez pas en laponie ben non non mais
cette bonne nouvelle pour beaucoup de
gens voient pour la magie de noël c'est
une bonne chose pour les fans les
laponie 1 pour être content ça s'appelle
comment des habitants devraient laponie
la première je me suis sentie limogés en
prob aussi déjà sur le dossier
alors je comprends votre des bombes
cherche c'est rare mais non il est
strictement interdit d'abandonner des
chroniqueurs en pleine nature c'est
beaucoup trop dangereux pour les animaux
sauvages
imaginez si à rennes 3 ans michel mr
c'est ça coûte bousiller noël par contre
vous avez raison la grosse actualité pmp
en ce moment c'est le départ la semaine
prochaine dans la famille mais comme l'a
dit cyril avec tout le stress des
qualifications il est pas bien mathieu
alors vous le savez chaque soir il ya un
billet à gagner avec ceux qui cherchent
à obtenir mon voyage et les autres qui
commande dans leur coin on voit vie que
tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes
motivations
on est tous on stresse
julie moi je vous adore toutes les deux
pour moi l'une ou l'autre
[Applaudissements]
les sionistes habitants comme les bonis
et bim
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi parler très mal de kelly au du
tout j'ai remarqué ça non je sais qu'en
fait vous parlais mal d'elle parce que
vous êtes amoureux d'elle on secret qui
avec la vérité ou l inverse
non non je crois que c'est plutôt cette
cette solution ou l inverse si sa vérité
on se rapproche pas mal voulez que je
vous fais un aveu vous allez qui la gc
de la pêche au bâti avec salif sadio
cette huître en soirée design date
ensemble c'est vrai ouais c'est vrai on
était rentrés en effet une date on avait
abattu peu bu à l'alcool à l'abus
d'alcool vous absenter peut-être et
c'est vrai qu'il y avait deux chambres
et je lui ai dit ben viens viens dans la
nuit aisne ça fait longtemps que j'ai
pas essayé
j'aurais peut-être dû mieux le vendre
s'était pas je vais tenter en laponie
avec la poudre ont menti spezza si je
parle
mais si vous partez j'espère qu'elle est
très jolie mais elle est vraiment très
sympathique cette fille est vraiment
très jolie mais elle est très sympa
compatible que bah oui souvent les très
jolis ils ont un peu chiante est ce la
peine
les bouchons sabatini est on arrivé là
on a là les gens sont sympathiques sur
le gâteau les boîtes aux les gens sont
sympathiques tout d'être à sa place ça
marche pas toujours avoir les deux voilà
sur la question que l'on se pose c'est
jour ni pascal pay s mais est ce qu'ils
aient une chance avec kelly en laponie
ah non la réponse est claire évidemment
non inscrits comme on le sait celui qui
devrait conclure avec elle lors de ce
voyage ses appuis et maxime gainey ça
fait un an et demi qui se tourne dans un
décor féerique ça se fait pas ça se fera
jamais assez moi en tout cas c'est ce
qu'a voulu savoir si reed dans un
contexte
[Musique]
[Rires]
elle est l'invitée spéciale gagne un mur
durant mon taux plein d'euros oui c'est
possible ça n'aurait par dépit ça serait
possible namehana qu'émane qu'un
animateur et l'autre comme un fusible
moins bien avec des chroniqueurs à
choisir entre maxime et vous je prends
dans maxim merci s'est répandue il est
très bon ah ouais allez vous savez
pouvait lire le monde aujourd'hui
vous savez que lui il est dégoûté de ce
que je lui ai fait le guet victoire quoi
qu'est ce cas c'est universal ses
patrons au maxi je trouve très beau ah
ouais c'est pas jaloux mathieu bas il
fait peur lui balayé tout costaud très
costaud on a demandé qu'on le touche il
a mal alors les mots dire que ce coût
était d original
bascou il ya un autre sujet qui agite
été pompés ces derniers temps à les nrj
music awards mais c'était chaud le débat
en plateau 1 c'est normal parce qu'il y
avait quand même une question
essentielle qui a divisé la france
entière pendant plusieurs jours comment
prononcer le nom de la chanteuse
aya nakamura nikos il a 40 ans de
carrière il est pas capable de bien
présenter une invitée le royannais
l'amour à ses musiques
il n'a pas encore signé john de terre
mais tu dis des conneries non parce
qu'on est bêtes aussi les noms attendus
des plus grosses que toi et de dire que
la chanteuse s'est pas c'est pas le top
gun kut à dire que c'est impardonnable a
été nerveux impardonnable tout ça parce
que nikos avait mal prononcé son nom
s'isoler gad elmaleh était venu dans
notre émission m'avait appelé j'aurais
vite au monde avait trouvé sa chute
[Applaudissements]
alors je voudrais pas me défiler et de
pas participer au débat débat très
important
benjamin l'a dit dire que cet artiste ce
n'est pas étonnant jaune c'est
impardonnable
tu as raison d'ailleurs comment elle
s'appelle cette chanteuse barre
[Applaudissements]
et de dire que la chanteuse s'est pas
c'est pas de dungeon tout à dire c'est
impardonnable carrière
[Applaudissements]
à sochaux la gfa excusez moi quand même
je suis pas trop con il faut je suis
chaud après ce match vraiment pas bon
c'est pas parce mac dont il veut
s'épargner ces dames et séduit smac très
fort ça et surtout les coups sûrs telle
issue qu'est ce qui peut lui sont si
c'est un arrosage automatique
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas c'est magnifique transition
pour le top gênant ces petits moments
bizarres de tpe dans cette journée il y
avait trois mois à retenir tout d'abord
le mot cette itinérance itinérance
itinérante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le premier président pardon c'est
un poète qui est beau et qui est très
beau
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
sinon bonjour blague je vais essayer de
solitude ma dernière
et moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous révéler un secret a réagi en lui
parce que vous avez montré jean michel
maire qui parlait à delphine et jean
michel m'a envoyé un sms dans la nuit il
me dit je parce que il me dit ça serait
quand même bien que delphine viennent en
laponie non pour des beaux parce que je
trouve que dans le casting
elle serait bien voilà et pour l'instant
ne vient pas et c'est vrai que vous
occupez beaucoup du texte du casting de
l'avant ça soit télégénique j'essaye de
respect des équilibres fois je suis un
peu éloigné de l'émission le concept du
prime ces plans cul en laponie
[Applaudissements]
non mais pas nul mais il a pensé lui d'
appât il a pas compris encore le
principe on va à la recherche du père
noël
waf est revenu à 14h30 dont je pense que
comme ken beaucoup filmé à 14 décarie
mais pendant quantité une nuit ça sert à
quoi la nuit c'était bien fait la ville
le jour au travail la nuit en keynes et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère qu'on aura jamais de coupures
de courant ne connais pas ce serait oui
donc on a su la liste des vêtements
condamnant à la polémique et -10 il y
avait un maillot de bain râler c'est
pourquoi pis y'a vous savez pas quoi je
sais un petit peu ce qui va se passer la
balle à amener un maillot de bain et pc
dans la vie ne serait pas au bout de vos
surprises et c'est quoi la fenelec dote
de jean-mi alors un nom mais sachez
qu'il y à un jacuzzi dans la maison love
tempêtes ont embrassé sa peau love story
mais avec vous je suis chez moi alors
moi je ne suis pas avec vous a ouvert
deux roues à part et moi je suis à pas
amendée ou nous apparaît dans l'ipad et
jacuzzi dans son hôtel
vous avez des d'un très bon truc et moi
je suis à côté dans un igloo vous êtes
sorte oui je vois l'esquimau tout froid
[Applaudissements]
il fera que 21 est ce que vous voulez et
sur le top 10 dont j'aurais pu être que
du mathieu parce que je sais pas ce
qu'il en aille trouvez pas qu'il a
changé a en ce moment je trouve qu'il
est exceptionnel et chafouin au crédit
pts 17 maxime ya deux semaines vous
allez faire une carrière alors merci
d'écouter il ya deux semaines j'avais
pas toute ma tête
merrimack si vous avez des soucis
sérieusement son bras on vous sent très
irritable en même temps tant mieux car
ça va permette de d'inaugurer une
nouvelle rubrique laïque au dtp npa
c'est très simple c'est des définitions
la langue française mais illustré par
des extraits de thé pmp ma chérie
juillet m'a jamais rien cgt la mer je
viens je viens michel sardou est très
jeune
si je peux me permettre
on peut ne pas aimer les reins du
shopping à vouloir faire l'amour dans
les faits ça tout le monde je vous jure
que c'est vrai que ne charrie pas du
tout je pense qu'il est vraiment
amoureux mathieu devoir non non vraiment
je pense qu'il est vraiment amoureux de
kelly et je pense qu en laponie
il peut vous faire une révélation et je
rigole mais essayez pas de refus de
dossiers sur quelqu'un d'autre pour que
non mais vous êtes number one vous êtes
devant kelly suis désolé ah oui en
laponie
je vais d'abord tenté non gibier si sa
foi j'ai kelly qui est charmante mais la
base c'est qu'il y regarder l'histoire
est très flattée par match a besoin d
aide
et on va l'aider alors la semaine
dernière est-ce que vous souvenez de qui
vous avez reçu quelques jours je ne sais
pas jean pascal et moundir et monday et
ça nous a permis de faire un point sur
la carrière de mathieu delormeau
ah oui parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
peu flou un jeu résume un peu star de
télé toilettant prochain sur nrj12
honecker vedette de tp acier à la place
de gilles verdez en semaine comédien de
taxi 6 7 et 8 et de plateaux s'il
n'existe pas on sait plus trop ce qui
fait de sa vie il était temps qu'il
aille voir un conseiller d'orientation
[Musique]
je pensais que j'allais finir sera
tranchée d'un vélo
ouais
[Musique]
faire
le tabou
m
ok nema
alors les mureaux 0
or le traitement cinq minutes à 24
heures
c'est moi
tes contacts aujourd'hui en transit mais
ce que je vends du
[Musique]
les métaphores
maintenant faites au cap mais moi je
tiens à dire à tous je pense de mon île
fait eu un début de saison exceptionnel
lâche alors je vous dis la chaîne
l'adorent ils veulent le mettre à ça
changeait alors ah oui il va le mettre à
toutes les sauces
non mais je vous jure et dire partout
dect est une émission pourquoi pas de
lanvaux pourquoi pas de l'inde
alors je suis en train de calmer la
veille bien entendu je vous dis quand
elle est lancée la bête c'est un feu
follet
oui on est entre mâles voilà dehors on
prépare des belles choses t'inquiète pas
tu sais c'est un truc de chez à l'abri
c'est là la grosse tête japonais à autre
chose philippe n'a pas l'air d'y croire
même si moi je sais je m'aime beaucoup
sur des trucs tellement insensé 300
n'aurais pas pu le dire dans les années
80 ce qui dit 90 c'est vrai qu'il avait
90 ont été peu préservé de ça quand même
un peu plus
vous êtes déguisé dirait la tenue de
challes vidre dans la soupe aux choux
monde
[Rires]
le glaude maintenant le glaude c'était
pas ça c'était la tendre et essayer
d'être prêt si un incident je me dis
c'est pas son truc à régional et par va
commencer par isabelle justement à ils
se demandaient si la participation de
syrie dans strike avait eu une
répercussion sur le dos de burger quiz
le même soir à jean michel avait son
idée sur la question
on avait donc
[Musique]
nous pensons pas que le fait d'avoir été
dans strike avec la guerre tu as
contribué à faire monter ce trac et du
coup baissé un peu le burger c'est
possible
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
a écrit mais vous vous êtes mignonne
mamère franchement non mais ça manger
bien et d'année vous avez quel âge la
14e' balance
[Applaudissements]
c'est halloween et on se dit que le
meilleur moyen de faire passer le
message c'est d'aller voir cyril hanouna
pourquoi parce que on connaît les
qualités humaines on connaît la
sensibilité était quelqu'un de sensé de
sensible et jérôme anthony qui a gagné
ce soir il a tout gagné
derrière
[Applaudissements]
moi j'adore ya maintenant il ya des
saucisses végétarienne ouais ok je mange
que ça c'est pas les 40 ans des galas
ses talons de victoria tu me fais de la
peine mais une voiture a chuté au hockey
tu les enfants écoutent tu viens de là
chez des copines on connait c'est à dire
vous ressemblez à victoria beckham
barman histoire alors
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est sûr
rouge
on aimerait venir
les gens me trouvent très bon là et les
amis je me suis fait la muscu je suis
j'ai pris globalement j'ai pris du temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m je pensais que ce n'était pas le vrai
père de rennes avait changé pas le tir
sans filtre j'avais jamais vu ça de ma
vie quoi on va rencontrer le père noël
et je vous rires jérôme anthony julien
audy j'aimerais jusqu'à vous aurez la
même carrière que lui les carrières
exceptionnelles et merci de dire un mot
c'est un garçon que j'aime énormément
c'était vraiment pour faire un jeu de
mots et voilà pour s'amuser parce que je
l'adoré car hier sur m6 j'ai pas la
moitié de sa carrière est vraiment
résolu blague de rachat mais je l'admets
je reviens juste deux ont eu ça va
[Rires]
pascal a dit moi non non amar dont il ya
eu un truc avant dans les questions
toujours pas ce que les gens appellent
me dire tu l'as d'or ça se voit trop
donc parfois je me permets tu as bien
trop balancé les gens me disent ah c'est
pour ça qu'on va beaucoup moins soir
[Rires]